it's just a sign waiting for an hour
so are you pleased on this video hi my
name is April hi I'm Blake hi my name is
Chester and my name is Becky and today
we're guessing cheap versus expensive
pad thai it's all gonna be delicious my
dad grew up in Thailand
a military brat earliest CIA Brad or
whatever so we've had a lot of Thai food
and Patty is not like my favorite thing
to go to but I mean it's kind of like
you order it with your food like you
order what you want and then you go oh
and also get some fun that's okay so
kind of like a side dish on a scale of 1
to 10 I love Pad Thai 11 and a half I
love it when it's extra spicy I love
when they put some egg in it and I love
just love noodles so it's so good I
normally only get shrimp eggs so this is
gonna be weird cuz I just started eating
chicken again
so I've never ever ever had chicken pad
thai so I might bring out nice wealthy
yeah I find that cheaper ones are a
little bit saltier so I would be able to
I think I would be able to suss out I
went to Thailand what so I'm by no means
I'm not an expert I'm excited let's try
some pad thai you ready to do this
let's go blindfolds up are you sure you
want green like I mean the red one looks
really cool you know I don't know you
know if you don't want the green I'll
take the it's up to you yeah yeah you
know that's fine that's alright okay
here we cheers for where's your fork
where are you okay there you are oh okay
do you have a D I don't know be funny is
that this isn't even pad thai and
they're just like messing with us like
this is actually Olive Garden's wait you
found the chicken can I use my hands
yeah are you okay
yeah this is C it was easy I did it the
comments better knock judges we're
blindfolded okay and I wash my hands
regularly like every time they need to
be washed and I something is on my fork
and I can't get it off sorry it's not
you know just melting in your mouth
obviously it's I don't I feel like that
chicken is kind of dry I would say it's
like medium price range cuz it's not
salty its flavorful but I don't think it
would be like the most expensive one
it's good I don't think it's expensive
yeah I don't think it's expensive but I
also think like cheap would be better
yeah but here's the thing
I feel like an LED expensive ones are
the fusion ones but this tastes like
legit pad thai yeah I mean it doesn't
taste like a fusion e thing do I look
cool or cool with the green one
I'm still kind of wondering like
well I figure we just Dutch ports oh why
don't we always end up in the same area
of the plate I want it is there anything
if there is nothing on this fork I'm
gonna be unhappy there's nothing on the
fork whoa whoa okay it's just on a table
now huh why is it kind of has like
barbecue sauce and I got some veggies
that I don't think are usually in packs
hi um yeah no this one's like a balsamic
taste or something to it like it tastes
like Italian dressing and it's all over
me I think it might be expensive because
like it doesn't taste like pad thai yeah
this is totally messing me up now it
tastes like a fancy chef decided you
wanted to make Thai food his own yeah
and then looked it up on the internet
and was like mmm I don't like how it
tastes so I'm gonna add barbecue sauce
it does taste like barbecue sauce right
I don't I don't know this town actually
tastes a little more sophisticated so
maybe it's a little more expensive I'm
actually gonna agree with you I feel
like this is like the one that you would
get it like the fusion restaurant or
whatever like the nice restaurant and
the other one was just like Panda
Express oh that I felt substantial no
nope okay
yeah thank you they serve chow mein
there's not much time between the two of
them I think that this one is more
expensive than the first one we tried
I'm sorry who ever had to clean this up
but the noodles are a little bit more
I'll then take true I do like the bite
on the nouveau the noodles are good and
I let it get the extra vegetables was it
like a broccoli maybe but they're like a
pad thai that's why it's like so I would
like a bite to it like there's
definitely a vegetable with chew yeah
I'm going to say this is the more
expensive one in the first one was the
the cheaper one compared to the other
one who may have been a little more
expensive
are you guys gonna tell me if I have
something on my face
[Music]
it's just a sign waiting for an hour
so are you clicked on this video it
tastes more like pad thai than the
second one but it's a lot more blander
than the first one
yeah I like the first one the first one
was the best first one might be the
cheapest I barely got anything how do
you put it on your fourth do you like
stick and then twirl you just stab yeah
okay this is not classy
sorry yeah I don't know this tastes
similar to the first one mmm oh it's all
chicken there's a big chunk of chicken
oh my gosh hey you made a bigger mess
well I don't know that's kind of you you
would drop the whole piece of chicken I
feel like I underestimated and it was
hard to keep things on a fork I'm sorry
I'm sorry it's fine oh this is see this
is definitely an assist some sort of
weird vegetable the first one we had was
the cheapest PF Changs the second one
that we had which was a little bit
sweeter I think was the mid middle price
and the most recent one we had
so the first one we tried was the middle
one the second one we tried was the most
expensive and the third one we tried is
pink so I'm gonna say that first ones
the cheapest the middle one is the most
expensive and then the last one is in
the middle did you make the second one
yourself and did you put barbecue sauce
in it I think that is a curveball that
we should have been aware of because I
was thinking no one I was thinking the
most expensive because it was a fusion
yeah everything was coming from a
restaurant - yeah frozen adds a whole
new element to this those tricky you're
tricky I said that the cheapest of my I
said that the frozen one was the
expensive one I told you I don't have a
sophisticated palate I like
cheeseburgers even though the third one
was most expensive like if I'm gonna
pick one it's gonna be the middle one
maybe add a little chili oil to it yeah
that wouldn't tasted like it was from
tight house yeah I said like it was from
an actual entire restaurant that yeah he
knows what spice is Costa - yeah it
could be a little spicier the best like
that - everyone's own they ask you like
what number do you want no one else is a
number so yeah I mean obviously we don't
know our pad thai it's good harmless
yeah
[Music]